[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
super excited to be talking about
empowerment and clarity
we have Paris nests for joining us on
the show hello how are you thanks for
coming on Paris thank you so much really
excite for this we were just talking
about this beforehand but it does seem
like Junoon was the one that then
brought us together a couple years ago
at his events that he was producing and
then most recently we saw each other at
the interdependent capitalism event
absolutely which was so cool and I'm
glad that we caught on to the importance
of doing the show together to talk about
all these things absolutely thank you so
much for inviting me it's really a
pleasure I love what you guys are doing
here thank you
it's amazing thank you and your support
has been instrumental in helping us make
this thing happen so thank you and for
those that don't know Paris neces
background she believes change first
starts with yourself and you find the
links in the body blow to Paris's work
Paris I'll start things off with our
favorite questions to ask our guests
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our world yeah you know I knew you
were gonna ask this question of course
you know and I've been thinking about it
and you know overall I do see it going
in the right direction in terms of it
has become better
over the centuries over the over the
thousands of years you know I'm
homeschooling my kids and we're studying
about Mesopotamia and you know and the
evolution of civilization from that
region of the world and essentially you
know where we are today it's phenomenal
the things that we're doing the things
that we're getting done
the things that were achieving it on a
daily basis and so I think it's
incredible and but there are of course
some some things that we can obviously
improve on and in that thing they're one
of the most important things is not to
lose sight of our humanity of the human
effect that we all have it's easy to
become mechanical about our technology
about the innovations that are happening
and that we will be seeing in the future
in the not-too-distant future but that
you know there is a major part obviously
there's a major part of us who's who's
human who machine cannot replace I
believe that and I and I and I feel it
and I and I sincerely would advocate for
that humanity to continue rather than be
taken over by any kind of a cyborg or
transhumanism where it might go too far
for example and things of that nature
a couple things first it's crazy that
you're homeschooling your kids I mean
that's that's it's really awesome to me
I love the idea I mean I'm a huge
proponent of being able to help the
children
unpack what their purpose is in life and
figure that out from a young age and
sometimes the school system can squelch
the purpose rather than make it flower
and if you bring up the grade point of
like looking back at some of our older
days yes at times there may not be the
Internet but there were you just spoke
about these values these human values
that machine's can't have well back in
the day there used to be at times more
of this deeper human value spiritual
connection that's what it feels like and
today with the machines it feels more
lost yes and no for example we were just
we were studying Mesopotamia and and how
the language the language that we are we
are using today was first of all and and
it was through that particular region
that they created coulda first if I'm
pronouncing that right English is my
second language everybody but still I'm
still working on it so you can correct
me if I'm wrong but anyway it was
evolved then and and you know there that
the rules that were made by the then
King and to as to the behavior human
interactions and behaviors there are
pretty tough and and just recently in
the past hundred years we've been able
to translate that language that was that
was carved in stone thousands of years
ago to now understand what it was what
it had
and the the rules in the laws that were
made are pretty pretty steep where you'd
lose a finger you lose a hand if you
know if you should happen to you know
misjudge or I mean just happen to you
know look someone the wrong way or touch
someone's child it's just really very
steep so based on that kind of a legal
system and and societal laws I would say
we're much better off right now balanced
with being able to actually see the
stars no light pollution actually
gardening ones you oneself are actually
working with precious resources of the
planet oneself versus just walking into
the grocery store walking into the soup
this is the super centers yeah these
types of things but that's just it I
think the fact that any human being can
realize the tremendous power that we
have that is at our fingertips today and
make best of it and make the most of it
we would have any human being would have
lived will live thousands live thousands
of lives within their hundred year
lifespan because we are capable of
creating so much now than we were even
fifty years ago right I mean there's so
many different references that I that
the in my short life span I can come up
with and that that did not I couldn't
even have access to you know twenty
years ago and I wouldn't would be died
for and I didn't even know existed
whereas now all I have to do obviously
is write google it you know and you know
add it but I do agree where in the past
you might have asked a friend in the
past you might have gone to the library
you might have gone through more effort
there would have been more human touches
you know more more interactions right on
a human level to uncover you know your
research your you feel a study your
company you know any kind of development
that you are doing whereas now it is
available electronically I can see where
the
can rise I think the most concern is
really in the young the young are in the
worst position at this point where we
are where they are being given these
incredible machines and they are sort of
I think depending on the parental
guidance some are being left alone with
them and so you know there's different
levels right and some are given some
guidance some are given some parameters
and so on so I think the most vulnerable
are our young whereas the elders you
know them I'm an elder right now it
feels so I know how to use this stuff to
my benefit and and somebody who's you
know somebody younger than me that days
they know how to use this stuff to the
benefit right but definitely not the
tens definitely not even to teens I feel
yes oh there I feel that there needs to
be a lot more development in terms of
educating our children as to how to best
use technology for the benefits and
schools you know do don't do this very
well they try the ionised from our local
school program they really tried and my
daughter was enrolled in a parochial
school before a public school system and
they didn't even address technology you
know the computers were still in one
room and they still had you know
computer time like the way I had when I
was in college so I felt that that was
pretty removed you know I didn't like
that and then we came into a public
school system where everything is open
car blocks you know you've got the
internet go use it now you have Google
classroom all of a sudden my daughter
was able to email her friend's mom you
know to ask for a playdate and I didn't
even know about it until after the fact
that the mom then responded to me and
said oh you know your daughter reached
out and you oh really
I had no idea you know and so there was
no very little guidance given to the
children I mean we experienced this
first has to well what do you use this
for right yeah
and how do you best use it and what are
the limitations you know oh right that's
a good example of it being used for
purposes of trying to schedule a
playdate cool stuff and there's also the
prior to these last couple of decades of
the proliferation of the technology into
our pockets to have a hundred billion
humans prior to us figure themselves out
through their own trajectories of life
experience versus now if you don't
really know who you are when you're 12
or 14 or 18 there's algorithms that have
been crunching billions of psychometric
profiles that are feeding you pieces of
information that are trying to swing
your perspective and directions that may
align with their own ethos and not your
our own so there's some major issues
that are also arising from the business
models that they have and so it's like
this you gave a great example you know
reaching out for a playdate emailing the
mom cool but yeah yeah to also put the
power of the tech into the kids hands to
be manipulative is we don't even know
that we're building the tools that are
then manipulating us and so we have to
be extremely vigilant with the way that
we design it with the ethics and
philosophy and morality exactly these
types of things and we're not plugging
do we haven't plugged those things into
Silicon Valley since day one they've
been gone it was just engineers and
designers and ops people since day one
and the philosophy and ethics and morals
were like people shouting from across
the world like hey what are you doing
yeah and now it's like well maybe we
should have a couple of them that are on
our staff and then they get in there and
they're like oh my gosh we're there
there's no spiritual connection here
it's it's a void of spiritual connection
it's and so those and what leaks into
the voids of spiritual connection is
malevolence unknowing malevolence and
ignorance unknowingly
and we don't like to think of these
brilliant programmers as people that are
ignorant but when one has never felt
unbounded wholeness when one has never
felt sorcerer
the spirit that exists among us all and
it's just the constant in the head
programming we're we're we're puppets in
a sense for so there's there's a lot of
nuance there and I think we're gonna hit
on this throughout a little bit more
definitely let's do so let's do the
journey so this was cool you're teaching
me that you're born in Iran and then
that's actually very close to Armenia
we're very in the same yes area of the
world
neighbors and so what was that like for
you growing up because that was
obviously much prior to to you know to
my pigs I actually was never even you
know I was born in the United States I
only went back most recently two years
ago and going back I mean it was
beautiful but it's also like there's a
different pace of time there's a
different color completely different
culture
so yeah different different values of
families and neighbors and community yes
so tell us about it absolutely you know
I loved growing up in Iran I it was such
a peaceful and loving environment that I
remember obviously very modern at the
time and you know I the environment was
such that I remember it be there was so
much love and so much unity among our
family members and this is not just our
family members it was these are the
family values that are that exists in
that part of the world and I don't know
to what degree today I will be honest
and frank with you because that has
somewhat changed but back then it was
much more stronger solid family stayed
together and supported each other they
had each other's back you know multiple
generations live close together of
course you know we also travel to
different cities to see family and and
relatives but I remember that that the
love was so intense that that's when I
experienced one of my first epiphanies
at age of four whoa and it stick it
stayed with me throughout my entire life
and today it still drives me I felt I
will never forget that
with that this happened it was we were
bicycling in our famous street in front
of our home we had this beautiful villa
my dad was a he was into manufacturing
he created on the first manufacturing
plants to convert wheat to flour in the
province and then he later multiplied
them you know throughout the country and
he produced at one point top 10% of the
the of the gross production of flour and
you know in in Iran but in any event so
I remember the incredible love as I was
bicycling with a whole bunch of other
friends no complete trust right it's no
come back home at a certain time it's
complete trust and I experienced this
incredible expansion and unity unity it
was a felt hardcore body right there and
I saw it it was as if I was in a dream
but it was clearly not because I was
very much awake and the love and the
unity and the the the lack of barriers
that I felt between myself and my fellow
human was such an incredible experience
that stayed still stayed with me for at
fourth cool why and I was also so eager
to learn that my mom couldn't hold me
back I was the youngest of four and she
enrolled me in into kindergarten at four
and yes kindergarten at first I was I
went to first grade at five and I loved
I loved love learning and and then it's
also didn't it was also helpful to know
who the principal's were and so so far
there was a small city and so everybody
knew each other and so they made some
adjustments to get me in because mom
just didn't want to hear me anymore you
know having to beg her to go to school
and learn but anyway so it was a very
supportive environment loved loved Iran
I miss the country and so we left when I
was 11 to come to San Francisco to visit
my brother who would come here earlier
several years earlier we left at 77
and my father's you know decide that we
wanted to go and see him for the summer
vacation so we all packed and we came
straight to the SF it was beautiful and
and after a few months my dad's excited
this is an amazing place and you know
what we're moving and we're going to
have that the rest of the family moved
here as well and so then of course he
broke the news to the rest of us and and
the even though we had a democratic
family where my dad really liked to
involve the children and the
decision-making but that particular
decision-making I remember I was not
involved in it's pretty much made for us
and so luckily I mean I loved that of
course you know here you are 11 in a
completely different world I spoke
English to some degree but clearly not
fluent so I had to learn English quickly
and then I was next thing I knew I was
enrolled in school and and going to all
what a pivot in life trajectory is yeah
your father was kind of like you said
just in a sense just made that pivot for
you and the children
that's thankfully because you know and
then in retrospect we often asked him
did you know that there was going to be
a revolution did you know that there was
going to be changed because two years
later in 79 there was the you know the
hostage crisis in those JA about the
country and so on so forth and all that
change occurred and you know and he it
says that there he he had his hand into
the business world and into trade and it
wasn't just on a small scale was on a
large scale he had realized there's some
things that are just not going right
that there are some things that are not
quite connecting and he he didn't know
exactly what was going to happen but he
did realize that there was some things
that were not going the right direction
in terms of the country and the regime
so his gut he went with his gut and he
decided for us to stay and that was the
most incredible decision I constantly
thank him yeah there's not really a day
that I go by that I don't remember that
and I don't think the fact that we are
here in United States I love this
country I'm
American citizen and you know I though I
love Iran as well in terms of the what
we left behind but it's not the same
world as it was obviously back then and
we do we need to look for each other
definitely and you know the Iranian
people as well I'm sure you know this
you know and in Iran they completely
they love Americans you know I know of
course it's the regime and the politics
that's the that's the the difference and
that's creating a gap I think most of us
love each other that's true from all the
different countries just a regular
person the regular Joe wants to get
culture and wants to learn more about
these other cultures but I don't I have
to be careful because though fascinate
me this global government yeah yeah
that's a really good point so being of
having been born in a different country
and migrating here you know we realized
quickly that obviously we're not the
only ones and then you look around and
you see people from all over the world
coming to the United States and you see
how it was the experience that I had
within me and the questions that came up
for me as a on a human level you know
clearly well that has defined me and and
I think I'm grateful for that I think
migrating and changing one's environment
you know whether you're you want to
relocate move whether you want to
experience a different culture across
the world you've got to do it I really I
highly encourage people to do so because
it gives such an incredible perspective
into not only how you one yourself
adjusts to this new environment whatever
it might be new language new food new
people new characters new culture but
also
you see how other people are living the
same exact 24-hour day that you do on
the other side wherever you might have
been and how they are living it and and
then and then you see the interactions
that you have with them and then you soo
realize that we're not so different
that the gap is there is really no gap
and that it is perceived and it and that
it is based on so many other factors
that are not humanistic you know it has
to do with it couldn't economy obviously
it has to do with politics and salsa but
anyway yeah this is a very critical
point and I'm glad that we're attack
we're talking about travel with the lens
that we are when we have this global
mentality about the way that we can
maximize our collective prosperity I
think one of the most important keys
that is this travel let's do the picking
up of the interests as well so as you
move then you locate to San Francisco
where you know for the last 40-plus
years being here in the Bay Area is kind
of nuts seeing what's happened in
Silicon Valley this is completely
different than being in kind of like
rural Nebraska for 40 years because not
much changes in rural Nebraska for 40
years so like what has it been like
being here how did you pick up your
interest growing up in this area tell us
about that that's amazing you know I
when we moved here we moved right here
just to San Francisco directly there's
an area called Park Merced is right near
San Francisco State and so my brother
had an apartment there so we lived there
for about nine months and my father and
quickly got involved and he purchased a
house that was half built and then we
waited for it to be fully built before
we moved in into the peninsula and so
and then that transition in the into the
school system was huge I was faced with
bullying you know right off right off
the bat you know soon that hostage
crisis occurred and Here I am taking the
school bus in the morning you know in a
very nice neighborhood you already were
in Hillsboro and
you know and then you have kids that I
still know today that by the way we
attend our reunion you know junior high
reunion and high school reunion you're
screaming at me in the bus you know
death to the shop
death to the shop you know or you know
there were some other slogans that were
used and you know damn I have to tell
you though I'm so grateful that I my
character I mean I have you asked
yourself you know you we asked ourselves
throughout our lives about who we are
and so forth so on so forth I'm so
grateful that I have I have had a cheery
life you know and I think I see life and
in a very positive way and the cheer
cheer of in me and if you will a society
because I have lack of a better word has
saved me yeah I saw that but it you know
I didn't I never allowed it to go into
my heart I never allowed it to penetrate
to the point where it would block me you
know or hurt me to the point where I
would be isolated or I would feel you
know disempowered or anything I said so
I you know I realized that it was the
times and but I'm also but I also feel
that aspect of what I saw helps me feel
for children and adults that that do go
through a bullying of any sort or
minimization of any sort that minimizes
their capacity as a full human being
whether there might be you know as women
you know as as LGBT community whether it
could be in any particular kind of a
minority group you know I mean I see
that I feel that and I'm so grateful
that I had that experience because era
isn't it is such a limited perspective
of who who we are and but it also does
to help dovetails on the fact that the
monkey mind right the monkey mind that
we learn that you know you watch
something on TV and it transpires to you
right especially if you're younger and I
see so older folks to you know
transpires to one whether it's positive
or negative whatever that influences
which goes back to your conversation
about how we have this sort of a
pre-arranged
you know media right that comes at us at
a very precise and proceed with
precision right and and that's sort of a
feedback that you receive and I think
that us as humans need to truly elevate
our understanding of who we are and
really realize that we have free will
that we see s we see this stuff but we
have to really decide on our own whether
we want to react right to the stimulus
to the news to the to the interactions
or to the to the marketing gimmick
whatever it might be that we are
receiving you know these messages so you
have to realize this is why again I go
back to education not just for kids and
really for everyone for all of us to
realize that we have that free will we
have that free choice you know is it a
simulation I'm gonna go back to that you
know I mean you know so are we just you
know within this simulation where you
know everything is supposed to happen in
a certain way or you know it's
predetermined I mean there's all kinds
of different conversations I still say
we have free will it might be a
simulation to a certain degree in level
but we still have a free will to step
out of it to step out of it and to to
act upon our own understanding and to
ask our own questions right that's where
the empowerment is that's where the
that's where the freedom is that we so
want as human beings you know I've
experienced it so much and throughout my
life so you had questions going back to
a question being raised here I mean you
couldn't come to a more diverse place in
the world no yeah in San Francisco and
back in background we had arrived I
think Harvey Milk was the mayor of San
Francisco and I know now you know in
retrospect I did not know then growing
up here at the time but you know and
there was a lot of issues right clearly
you got shot and saw so for there's a
lot of issues about that about the
daylight
in a community and their rights and I i
also questioned that you know i also in
myself wondered about rights not just as
a as my as a woman but as a human being
and as a somebody who wants to love
someone else you know and you know I Who
am I to say who are we to say right and
to to to condemn and judge another human
being based on the way that they choose
to love and I remember so I remember
studying of course you know as you go i
so i went to crocker and then after that
I went to Eragon high school and and the
same people that made fun of me in the
bus were and became my friends and then
you know we evolved together and it was
it's it and I have to tell you I had I
felt like the entire entire high school
was my friends I didn't have any
particular group that I hung out with
though I did have some really good
friends that I that I still cherish the
friendship with now but you know I have
to also say that living here I felt and
I don't know maybe I tell me if you hear
this from other people I felt this
osmosis
I felt that guys if I am constantly
being fed or I'm receiving information
you know I I felt like I said I'm a
receiver and I'm receiving information
on different levels and the information
then I would see it come to fruition
through other channels you know sue
definitely right yeah and whether it was
oh this company is now popping up it oh
I had that idea you know or or you know
this this thought of you know unity or
this thought of you know knowing that
for example I have to tell you Gavin
Newsom when he was uh it was the mayor
of San Francisco I was doing some
programming at Commonwealth Club and I
so much wanted to meet with him in
person and it didn't it did it did not
occur unfortunately but but that's okay
the point is that I knew in my heart and
probably so many other people that he
was going to become the governor
it's just kind of know that and and so
many other so many other examples and it
and it brought the question to me that
of environment the environment that we
live in and the clarity of of ourselves
to be able to receive this kind of
information and and then the seeker
within the human you know that that
exists within all of us and I know for a
fact that all of us have these things
it's not one specific person that is a
incredible genius and of course there
are but that will blocks it and as I
realized throughout this time is that
you know things like fear right greed
lies things like you name it jealousy
that these basic emotions block the it's
sort of take our body that is aligned
and it kind of yeah
takes you out of whack out of the divine
alignment with your purpose or your
mission and unity they said two things
how do you vaccinate yourself against
the twisting exactly so I have that same
question these are great questions I've
asked and you were asking the same thing
so I've dug into this there are ways
that you can lack of a better word
protect but really understand yeah I did
I try to dig as deep as I can understand
why it happens and how you can sort of
eyes you say vaccinate yourself is you
know one a seek the knowledge right get
to know yourself and get to know your
own buttons right it triggers you yeah
you know what what is the cause of the
fear that you might mean some people are
petrified of spiders you know I've in in
or the other side of the political
spectrum or the other side of the
political spectrum yeah
where'd that come from exactly spiders
because spiders is probably like less
than a percent of people but the other
side of the political spectrums like 25
percent thank you for that intersection
I appreciate that yeah definitely just
so good to be able to know yourself to
the point that understand that we are we
are we were brought up in a certain
family setting we were brought up in a
certain environment God had everything
to do with how we think and has
everything to do with how we behave you
know and and that question and this
question was also question for me what
percent just for a book set in Shelby
DNA right what percentage it are we our
behavior is environmental yeah and you
know I have to tell you the majority of
it is environment majority yes you have
certain DNA but you at the same time the
majority of what sort of steers you you
know this DNA this is sort of a pure
being that the steering is the
environment and so you've got to know
your own manual you have to know your
own manual how are you you know and what
why are you doing what you're doing what
are you here for there is you know I've
asked myself is there really a purpose
right is there really a purpose a common
purpose for all of us is there a
personal purpose you know big desert you
know very deep questions right and the
question and the answers wouldn't come
right away
but if you'd stay with it long enough it
will come and so I realized at this
point in my life
finally I'm a half a century old and I'm
proud to say it I haven't you know I
have no problem saying my age where some
woman might you know I might here for my
friends later why did you tell your age
but does it matter but the point is that
I'm grateful because half a century has
taken me to come to the point of
stillness and to the point of resolve
you know it's it's incredible it's a
celebration it is a celebration some a
lot of people apparently pass without
getting to that point and
that's unfortunate that we've made a
world where that happens and that people
aren't able to commune with the infinite
and achieve their divine purpose figure
themselves out their own OS their own
manual within even the first 25 years of
their life children should be figuring
it out faster we should be facilitating
the social fabric to help children
figure that out faster that that is that
would be a an incredible goal that would
be the I mean you would think that
that's what the education system it
tries to do here not really yes to some
degree I think it did do add education
system does help understand the
environment that we have stepped into
yeah but it also has the ability to form
and shape the thoughts right of those
individuals depending on what part of
the United States did you go to you know
high school right and what what kind of
curriculum was given to you but I think
that at the at the end it's the
objective mind you know you have to
always go back to the objective mind and
that is the sort of the highlight I feel
that that we need to that I'd like to
help people realize that yes you might
be in a certain environment right a
certain environments are really not that
great right for whatever reason and that
you might some people might have been
born into his some people might have
been have gotten into that particular
path and I'll say this is an example my
brothers they were they had loud you
know lead interesting lives and anyway I
can go into detail about that but not to
digress so I feel that and hope we could
talk about that would you like to well
that leads us into us being in charge of
our own destiny
which we were just talking about mental
health yeah yeah I mean because we're
talking of now again so many people are
experiencing issues with mental health
across especially the developing world
and so many of the ancient wisdoms that
have been lost are speak about things
like we just had feel bored us on the
show talking about crazy wise film
things like the should divine rituals
and shamanic practices of the indigenous
and verses now just drugging ourselves
with pharmaceuticals so we're we're way
misaligned with nature and it almost
seems like there's something dark that's
keeping that ignorant and malevolence
are there purposely instead of that
connection of the divine well you know
it's interesting so medicine you know
the the sign if you look at the American
Medical Association I don't know if you
know that the seismic double pilots over
cross the yes the staff and then the
wings yeah
said that sign originated thousands of
years ago from the pineal gland was it
or that the pinecone was at the top or
something like that something
interesting what that sign it goes you
know so I studied the chakra system and
I have also I'm also a meditation
teacher and while I was studying this we
came across the sign and we studied it
well so apparently this sign has been
taken from an ancient tradition and it's
it's a known fact and basically it is
describes the body the staff is the body
is fine spine yep and these spirals are
two snakes yes that spiral in between
the two chakras
yeah chakras and the choppers are also
equivalent to certain Glen's in the body
that are a pathetic weight to the
doctrine system mm-hm
so it intertwines these these chakras
and then the wings are at the center the
heart where earth meets heaven thus
wings to fly into the heavens fear
then from the heart the center that
where the wings are and then and then on
to you know consciousness achieve the
consciousness level of awakening and the
the full spectrum of the Lotus that's
cool so that is the that's our medic
medical basis is incredible you know the
medicines that were able to create
actually in the pharmaceutical companies
and what we were able to do is
phenomenal I mean that is phenomenon the
most positive was never like that it's
supposed to help us with us scent
however it is yeah it can be misused
right there are we soft deal thing
absolutely this is what I mean in terms
of of staying objective and and staying
true to oneself and knowing that we can
anyone i remembers i one of my teachers
just to say pre paris you're you can
you're in danger of getting off the path
at any given time and i used to think
this is my meditation teacher which I
highly respect and really helped me
realize quite a lot right personally in
my life and so I'm grateful for that but
he said that he would continuously say
this and I'm I used to dismiss it it was
it I felt it was a scare tactic you know
but now I realize what what he's meaning
because it is true if you can if you
lose yours the sense of yourself you
know you also used to say that we need
to hang on to your rope and the Rope
inside within who you are you've got to
hang on to that there will be tough
times in life there will be there will
be times and you will get challenged
there will be times that you might have
to take these medicines be right and
that the medication might take over the
body but you've got to under all
circumstances hang on to yourself yeah
hang on to your path
and not lose sight of that because you
wants you do that's when you're knocked
over yeah that's when you know you go
off track that's when you from fear off
that's where accidents happen that's
where problems occur and sometimes they
happen maybe to a high degree where that
person might have a hard time getting
back yeah right yep Daniel that's a test
of faith that's a challenge huge and
then you have the intervention world
coming in stepping in wanting to do
interventions wanting to do some kind of
uh you know saving healing which is all
wonderful but the missing link is that
person that person inside that
objectivity that human being that so has
to agree has to want has to have that
that that way back if they're so far
gone regardless of what anybody does on
the outside yeah they may not get back
on track I mean I don't want to be a
fatalist
you're right you're right at the same
time I have to say I've learned this
from experience and I say this from
firsthand my brothers were both my
oldest brother had a drug addiction that
has somehow worked itself into his life
at an early age and it was a horrible
thing for him and for our family it was
awful at witnessing all that and what
and seeing that how much he really
wanted to make that make the change in
the transition but on how difficult it
was to do so and as soon as something
would go wrong or not his way he would
be back on you know using drugs and but
the point is that that was one incident
my second brother was a was someone who
was incredibly healthy he stayed away
from anything that was that could
possibly hurt him he was he was an
athlete he was a it was she was black
diamond skier you know snow snowboarder
I mean you know water skier he taught me
everything about the outdoors you know I
love to camp
he was an electrical engineer he played
the guitar he's saying I mean he was
just like you know this creative
human being and he was misdiagnosed with
depression and here comes medications to
help him get better well guess what it
never got better and one more and then
one more and let's take this for that
side effect and let's take that for this
side this is in the 80s where mental
health wasn't really talked about very
much and while there's a nice little
bribe coming under the table for each
one of the medicines that's being
prescribed and nobody knew we had no
idea you know my father was you know
what was you know he believed in doctors
who believed that he you know it wasn't
his profession right so he would leave
it up to the other experts to help and
same with my mother you know and so with
the hats of trust
Oh what else are they going to do but
then soon they realized they skeptical
this is one of those lessons yes exactly
there was a lesson for me as a child
watching this unfold yeah it was a huge
huge life lesson
I'm grateful now you won't repeat that
with your kids absolutely not with
myself I was very cautious with and help
remind your friends of that too yeah
exactly exactly so you can then take the
knowledge and run horizontal with it
after you've experienced it vertically
through your own family over time you
can then share with other families
absolutely I am so looking forward to
doing more of that yeah because there is
so much trust that's put into weight
like again I don't I don't feel that we
should not trust trust is a great thing
yeah but it's good to also have healthy
skepticism yo yeah and I learned that in
my audit career at PwC you know you were
an auditor you audited right financial
statements but with a skepticism
we weren't suspicious that things were
going to go wrong or that you know
there's miss statements or that you know
the the books are accounted for in a
wrong way but that you looked at it with
objectivity that something could be out
of whack you know so that kind of point
of view is imperative yeah yeah right
yeah and so
the medication world I think is great
but at the same time it is so filled
with so many side effects and so many
overlaps and that I on I don't speak for
the doctors but I really need companies
when you when you really need innovation
I mean just some simple apps that can
help us see the decide affects you know
does this really work with that you know
there are a few but there aren't enough
on a large enough scale where we can
just use it at our at our fingertips
right you know so that kind of a thing
would be wonderful for for humanity you
know for us to a full simulation a full
digital twin of Paris Nessa and then you
can simulate what it's like adding a
little pharmaceutical to your entire
body state and seeing what it does
exactly and along those lines you know
medication is is great but I also have
to fit my personal philosophy is short
term if it's a long-term medication you
have to really look into what's going on
with the body what's going on with the
on the emotional level hence the chakra
system that I've studied and that
there's a there's a system in the body
that has that has emotions you know we
have our emotional mind right psychology
is all about the emotional mind and so
on so forth well there's emotions that
we hold and literally inside of our body
and though it cannot be proven you know
we can't say oh this is the glass the
body holds the score yeah the body holds
the score and it has memory right body
muscle memory we talked about this in
athletics athletics so the body holds
these memories from way back when we
don't even remember right so most of the
equations occasions that have occurred
to us but that we have we have some kind
of a phobia or we have some kind of a
fear or certain kind of looks or certain
kinds of appearances certain
environments make us you know my field
make us feel uncomfortable well guess
what these are the body's ways of
telling you that you need to look
further into certain areas whatever the
the queue is rather than run away from
it it's the exact opposite you know it's
it's like oh it's an invitation the body
is trying to talk how else is the body
going to tell you yeah you know you've
got this is what I mean in terms of our
own manual manual and learning our own
learning about ourselves because the
body is incredible it's very wise right
yeah
and you know we're natural leaders xxx I
was looking this up earlier 37 trillion
cells and each human body and I think
it's we're still counting
that's not blowing and who's in charge
of that well you put inside of yourself
is pretty much in charge of that will
you surround yourself with is in charge
of that so you have a direct effect on
all of the all of your body all of the
cells in your body all the organs but
depending on what you take in what
stimuli from your environment taking the
food nutrition from suta clothes all
this stuff they that you taken exactly
there are two things that we can do that
I've discovered that can help clear and
flush in a way food and food I mean food
that's it's healthy for the body and
exercise yeah these are two third basic
stuff do your research longevity the
more you do research sleeps a good one
for sleep is excellent for decreasing
inflammation
yes helping you with better ly better
integration of your of the day with the
previous life existence the processing
process processes and kind of takes
everything and puts it into order
organizes right yeah and then you get up
the next morning fresh right super
simple ones yeah and that's it exactly
super simple Occam's razor is really
this is Occam's razor at its finest just
the most simple ways of living a healthy
life are likely the most optimal so
in ways that feel really good for you
and sleep really well exercise really
well and you'll likely feel great
day-to-day and be able to get through
some of those things that can stress can
give a stress or anxiety or reliance on
exogenous substances to make us feel
divine all these types of things
yeah exogenously success yeah versus
endogenous there are things found within
yet exogenous is when you seek things
outside of you too they try to get
yourself to yeah you want to be
endogenously motivated too because if
you're logically motivated to achieve a
divine goal you'll find yourself less
ego driven less money driven less Fame
driven and more purpose driven whenever
it's for things outside of you that
you're driven for you'll never find
satisfaction in something and people can
smell that on you they can smell when
you're like buying your next watch and
buying your next thing versus they can
tell when you're you know truly living a
humble existence meanwhile you're doing
really big things for the world and
you'll gravitate other people towards
you yeah it's beautiful absolutely I
mean you know we're intelligent right
humans are incredibly intelligent beings
and and also very basic you know but the
food that we eat right and you guys I'm
still serious about this really we are
in charge of all of us are not there is
an ignorance among us yeah well the
ignorance is not seeking the ignorant is
also not some big nurses within all of
us there's just different levels of
ignorance yeah yeah it we know that we
know so little yes yeah dunning-kruger
effect it's a great one there's a lot of
my guys that don't know
they think they know at all that's the
problem
there's a loud it's terrible yeah yeah
sure that need it there I have to tell
you I mean you know cuz I was reading
about this this new innovation or
actually got it's called a a new way of
up of helping to better our lives by
vice by by tweaking our brain into not
feeling neuromodulation I think so
that's thank you where you don't feel
pain suffering you know all the awful
things that can happen on invasively
like through ultrasound or through like
optogenetics through your eyes things
like that through light using light or
using ultrasound itself however way that
means like magnetic stimulation
electrical stimulation any things that
are transcranial just to not scare
people yes or not towards yeah yeah yes
yes but I think that's I mean I think
that's a noble I understand where that
concert you can also accidentally fry us
yeah it can actually fry you to I mean
let's be real like we fry so many rats
in these experiments all the time
unfortunate mice chicken cows pigs the
most unfortunate species on the planet
right now I'm glad I'm not one of those
animals being tested upon us for sure
someone's gonna do it someone's got to
do it yeah Rick Paris says that you know
we can't incarnate into an animal it's
like human is the
highest form of evolution and I
respectfully disagree I think it's a
open game the only way we're going to
understand not to destroy and kill these
animals is to be one and the blip of a
lifetime well you know I mean I think
virtual reality can help with that
whatever it takes sir on the VR headset
and and throw them in a pool so they can
feel like being a dolphin exactly so
make them go at like 20 miles an hour in
the water it's often experience or a
peacock oh sure you know that's just it
to put yourself into something else's or
someone else's position you know and
that's your empathy perspective behind
those eyes yeah cuz then you can yeah if
you feel like you're a mouse that's
being oh why don't we try this new
transcranial stimulation technique on
you and then it's like and then you're
like yeah we maybe we should chill out
with yeah definitely I mean you know you
wouldn't even know what that means right
and you wouldn't the world are you do it
there's so many different you know ways
that we humans harm each other
unfortunately right and and some
intentionally and some unintentionally
and I go back to the family the family
unit is the first unit that you come
into right as a human being and the
family unit is is such a integral and
important part of our lives but that
also we will be in most all of us will
become defined by that but then to know
that you are that you're still free to
step out of it right and to realize
because we've got our free mind to
realize right in from the wrong you know
I mean it's hurting someone hurts you
know it's painful that's not good right
I mean you know just our basic sense of
wisdom that we we're all equipment I
hope well you guys might say us
otherwise from your conversations but
you know that kind of a ability to to
then judge in a healthy way that is
something that needs to continue to you
know be developed and nourished and know
that you're not confined by the family
you know that you might be your one was
born in a family and raised by a family
and that's all wonderful but if it were
not optimal that there are many choices
outside of that whereas I think that
unfortunately not enough people people
realize that you know we have suicides
right teenage suicides are all-time high
you know and even it's pop stars you
know I mean and I mean Robin Williams I
mean the point is that to be able to
know that there is a different life
right different way of living and to be
able to access it yeah that's the beauty
of we're where we are today that you can
access it that there is information that
you can connect to someone else across
the world right someone else in another
country you mean you don't even have to
speak their language anymore you know
Google Translate for the most part it's
not perfect but still right so anyway
the point is that this is exciting we
were an exciting time in our lives
yeah when you're more immersed in nature
in the days of more tribal indigenous
days if you know it does almost feel
like there was a deeper ability to get
behind the eyes of others or get behind
the eyes of plants or animals or
anything else that was outside of the
eye and then so many of the things
especially with the uproar of the West
which did well in many ways with this I
of course at the same time took us so
far away from getting behind the eyes of
other people and plants and animals and
the planet and so many of the other
integral components to the unity feeling
so the ego is up roaring and the eye is
up roaring meanwhile the men
tality of being able to get behind the
perspective of others is all these
different unique combinations of humans
that are in all their parts of the world
and we're just so stuck in and sometimes
twisted we're stuck and twisted instead
of stuck in at least aligned mm-hm and
the best is to not be stuck be aligned
and be able to get behind the unity of
all the other perspectives why there
were so many churches right
I mean Church in your three history was
a savior for for many people where it
helped give guidance it helped give away
to a line right and there's it's it's a
code right and so the church is one of
them you know Bible is one of them today
is that many of the world religions are
exactly just that we're you know then
then you've got the the unfortunate
issues that come up within the religion
and you've got the you know the Catholic
priests molesting you know you've got
all these other negative stuff that
happened that sort of my mask right your
views of something that is supposed to
be divine you know and it is a savior
setting and but then again that's that's
where the objectivity has to kick in you
know you realize that you don't want a
bad apple yes Karen rot you know that
specific package maybe or that specific
rack but it doesn't rot the whole
foundation and the foundation is based
on something solid right so you have to
be able to stay objective that that's
what I what I continuously you know see
and it comes up regularly is that again
with the media with the with this with
the self-actualization with the
realignment yeah yeah and we have a
whole bunch of other points to get
in another conversation together I mean
we have this has been a very fascinating
conversation that's been going in so
many different directions that's
wonderful yeah I've had a lot of fun
going to all these different places
together may we ask you a couple of our
questions on the way out yeah where do
we come from into these earth suits on
this planet do we come from somewhere
beyond this 3d reality do we go back
after we die how do you feel about yeah
you know I thought that is a question
also that I've been trying to figure out
I'm not fully there with regard to
reincarnation I don't know I'm not I
haven't adopted that there is there is
science guide you also look into science
to have some kind of a proof there is
science that backs that there's at the
time that the fetus is developed with
the very first stages there's a spark of
light
it's part electric electric light or
electric activity that goes on and that
that is that is actually something that
has been watched and and has been proven
in crawl across so are we that mm-hmm
and and that has been a question for me
as well when someone dies when some cute
animal dies where does where does that
life go yeah I had that has been a
question for me for many years I
remember many many years more than 20
plus years I don't know the answer to
that
I don't know yeah the spark of
electrical activity and inception is
quite interesting
yeah what's actually going on is that
just so just the heart beginning its
pulsations or is that something deeper
with maybe the essence of the being
arriving or there's so yeah some crazy
stuff that could potentially there is a
cycle there's kind of a recycling if you
will of us the body that's from Earth
goes back to third
there is a recycling that is definitely
going on and that is clear to me and
whether or not the meat that's in me is
part of that recycling mmm right
when flower blooms then it dies then it
goes whereas where is this fragrance
yeah are we the fragrance right the
fragrance has you know it was here we
enjoyed it we we can say yes it was
present right but then it sort of joins
the collective right because now if you
can't go ahead and get gather all that
at a sense right and Isis back and put
it back inside the flower right it's
already expanded so are we that yeah
right and that that would be something
more along the lines of what I would
perceive it to be but I just given that
I don't feel that we should go around
hurting each other that were anything
less that just because maybe we recycle
you know and that we come from Earth and
we go back to Earth Day and that gives
us the you know carte blanche to you
know to imprison you know thousands and
millions and commit genocide and I mean
all kinds of you know horrible things
that go around the world you know
drive-by shootings and you know master
it that you know it doesn't give us the
right to to take away life from someone
else right and that is a huge question
and yeah yeah you will started
addressing this earlier in the show are
we in a simulation yeah she answered
that why do you ask her again she gave
us a very she answer that for those that
are ignorant like myself oh why don't I
pay attention to your guess was what was
the answer yeah I feel that there we are
an assimilation at a certain degree she
was talking about free will yeah she
heard her opinion
is the same as mine and if it's a little
bit of assimilation we still have to
play the game we do have we have to play
it like a game we are part of the
simulation
you either succumb to it and let it rip
you to pieces
eat you up and spit spit you out what
pay attention well you have to be in a
way because you know we are code right
behind all of this stuff is a code you
know there is that it's clear whether
it's a flower Fibonacci the whole
universe the whole definitely seeing
that yeah there's all kinds of food
there's definitely code behind all this
but does that mean that but I still have
to choose you know I still have to
choose AP you still collapse the futures
you you still choose but but see when
somebody is not in congruence when
someone is out of whack then they are
living in simulation but they are not in
unity with it see okay to be in unity
with with our our environment I'm just
going to call it right is an incredible
gift it's not a bad thing it's an
incredible gift because it's kind of
like launch when you want to launch a
spaceship into space you have to have a
rocket and you have to have a man or a
woman people in that rocket right that
take you to outer space to experience
that you have to have that rocket the
rocket is our body we have to have our
alignment right if we're out of back
what we won't be able to go anywhere
anywhere we won't blossom like a flower
you know just the congruence you know
with the experience that we're all in
right now yeah you've got to align
yourself and those who don't are the
ones that unfortunately lose it and you
know or miss out not lose but miss out
on their full potential on the full
potential exactly
and then what do you think's the most
beautiful thing in the world free well
it has to be free well for me I've gone
through so many numerous experiences in
my life where I've had that as a threat
to be taken away whether it was through
marriage or through dogma through
religion so on so forth I'm so grateful
that that I have that free will that
have that objectivity inside me that can
save me Jim what a way to look at these
norms that yeah that if yeah if we if we
if we're not vigilant with our own
sovereign tree then we can gain forces
can come in and take it away and yeah
that's applicable to dog most marriages
to these devices and the ways they
manipulate us the way that sometimes a
physician or pharmaceutical or so many
yeah hijacked our project yeah and a lot
of people walking but are they really
they're right damn yeah we've talked
about that on the show that one's scary
that one's really scary don't be afraid
don't be afraid but like how do you but
how do you know that I'm really here
well I can see you I can also sense you
there's when you get into more
clairvoyance you can actually see
people's colors their auras and what do
you see about my flora I didn't say I am
there I I will tell you this thank you
for asking that question I respect that
but the point is that I actually was
able to see those things at one point
and I thought the world I was so excited
so it's so incredible but what I did not
realize you can lose it oh that's that's
intense
yeah it's a practice that you
have to continue to develop and if we
don't continue to practice it and and
there's so many different levels of
clarity cleanse cleansing and yeah
toxicity that goes on in the body and in
the environment so if if if any of those
that are again out of whack then you
lose the perspective of the abilities
it's kind of like like a sixth sense
right so so then it would be like what
level of alignment is your aura like are
you on absolute fire with divine
connection to all that is and your
purpose or are you like a little tiny
flame or is this energy field yeah every
single one of us have yeah and the aura
is complete when it is full right around
the body and it has different layers in
different colors an energy field that
has been compromised has holes you know
some people feel well I can't get
fulfilled
you know they continues to do things and
try to write it's a lot of people go to
eating right yeah they eat a lot of food
because they want to feel life they want
to feel alive or for whatever reason
they're they're feeling empty well it's
not the food there's there's something
going on with the aura there's a break
there's some kind of a hole that's
taking away all the energy you know so
in order to replenish you've got to go
back to exercising you've got to go back
to having a healthy diet yeah I go back
to having that you know healthy sleep
nature connection nature connection hug
some trees make sure your friends around
you you know our friends are really
important our friends family yes yes
right thank you receiving the input that
is positive for you to do to replenish
that's beautifully said what a great
pend
yeah some indigenous people call that
spiritual fragmentation that's there and
and then we fill the void or the void
gets filled with malevolent forces that
take us away from all those things you
listed sleep exercise nutrition family
friends community divine purpose yeah
Wow super excited for another
conversation that was not yeah like that
please wow that was so good Thank You
Paris thanks everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking have more
conversations that your friends family
co-workers people online on social media
about things like empowerment clarity
and all these other subjects that we
talked about in this episode huge shout
out to Ron Vargas for producing and
directing thank you very much Ronnie and
also check out the links in the bow to
Paris's work to check those out follow
up with her if you'd like and also
support the artists entrepreneurs the
organizations the spiritual leaders
around the world that you believe in
support simulation help us grow our
links are below patreon cryptocurrency
paypal design cool merch and get paid
all that good stuff down there and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams in the world we love you
very much thanks for tuning and we'll
see you soon peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]